dietmar arnold seit rund 20 jahren
erforscht er berlins untergrund und hat
1997 den verein berliner unterwelten
mitgegründet
sein arbeitsplatz hat keine fenster und
liegt rund acht meter unter berlin
zehntausende kubikmeter schutt haben er
und sein team hier über jahre
ausgetragen und damit unterirdische
baudenkmäler freigelegt zb
brauereikeller und fluchttunnel die idee
dazu kamen diesmal erneut in paris als
ich 1988 den stadt- und regionalplanung
verliert habe gab es ein ausschnitt
pariser stadtplanern und ich bin da eine
gruppe von katar vielen geraden die also
sozusagen die katakomben unter paris
erkundet haben es gab drei
rivalisierende gruppen und bei der 1
ich habe dann geholfen zu vermessen und
weiß nicht was man also zwei tage mit
dem man unterwegs und habe ich mich
infiziert
und dann kam ich zurück nach berlin
dachte ich muss mal gucken was ist
eigentlich unter dem boden der eigenen
stadt los dieser neu gebaute zugang
führt zu einem der letzten fluchttunnel
mit denen menschen aus der einst
geteilten stadt von ost nach west
gelangen sollten
17 ddr bürgern sollte er den weg in die
freiheit ermöglichen es fehlten nur noch
zehn meter aber dann flog der plan auf
einer der tunnel gräber war der
west-berliner klaus köppen er wollte so
seine schwangere frau zu sich in den
freien westteil der stadt holen ist der
einzige tunnel dem man tatsächlich als
im original sehen kann
aus der zeit der berliner mauer
auch viele hilfsmittel und werkzeuge der
tunnelbauer sind im original zu sehen
[Musik]
oberirdisch markieren platten den
verlauf des tunnels von west nach ost
die teilung der stadt fertig war arnold
leben geprägt es gab freunde im osten
der stadt die ihn nie besuchen konnten
1964 wird er im westteil geboren
zum studium zieht er in die nähe der
grenze an der bernauer straße
wenn ich jetzt aus westdeutschland
besuch bekommen habe und die freunde
bekannte verwandte auch da bin ich die
zum brandenburger tor gefahren das war
also bei uns eigentlich auch verpönt
wenn man hier an die bahnhofstraße und
ist quasi an jeder straßenkreuzung gab
so holzpodest auf der westseite die
waren so hoch gebaut dass man von dort
aus richtig über die mauer ganz weit
nach ostberlin rhein gucken konnte ganz
in der nähe liegt seine stammkneipe der
bi michel
[Musik]
seit seiner jugend spielt er akkordeon
heute am liebsten lieder aus den 1920 er
jahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin ein echter berliner muss man so
auszudrücken und ich freue mich einfach
dass also auch bei den jüngeren leuten
sogar noch interesse an diesen liedern
da sind die sind ja zum teil richtig
brandaktuell wenn man sich die texte der
20er jahre da anguckt und es können also
hier auch einige mitsingen und ich finde
also ich kenne so gerne dafür
deswegen sehe ich das auch das soweit
nie aus stirb genau wie die berliner
eckkneipe die darf auch nie aussterben
und die freilegung von baudenkmälern
unter den straßen von berlin will der
54-jährige auch so lange kämpfen wer
kann diese brunnen von 1863 ist eine der
letzten entdeckungen er gehörte zu einer
brauerei und führt noch heute wasser
derzeit gesichert des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts von der kaiser hat über die
weimarer republik über den erst seit
über die nachkriegszeit und die deutsche
teilung und die wiedervereinigung wir
haben ja alles wirklich erlebt man kann
hier also geschichte wirklich toll
vermitteln eben nicht nur über sondern
auch unter der erde
das beweist dietmar arnold mit seinem
verein berliner unterwelten